the mule a powerful men telecommuting
from the planet Gaia used his power to
establish his empire incrementally his
mutations gave him a freakish outward
appearance his nose was abnormally long
sticking out nearly three inches from
his face the rest of the flesh around
his face appeared to be stretched across
his skull his body was spindly and
gangly and his limbs met at awkward
angles his appearance was one of the
reasons he faced such alienation in his
childhood he obtains the military power
of the kingdom Clegg on by mentally
altering the warlord ruler of the planet
the mules conquest is incredibly fast he
manages to defeat the First Foundation
and establish the union of planets his
own Galactic Empire of which he was the
first citizen the meals Empire would
ultimately prove to be short-lived
however suddenly he stays his advance
and goes into solitude secretly fearing
the mysterious second foundation who
were rumored to have the ability to
defeat those with mint eligibilities
such as his the book second foundation
published in 1953 revolves around the
Mules search for the second foundation
in its first part titled searched by the
mule the second foundation is elusive
and the mule wishes to use his newly
acquired resources to destroy it hon
preacher a former member of the
underground Opposition was converted and
he along with an unconverted man named
belch anise are sent in search of the
second foundation channeis who has
quickly risen through the ranks and
impressed the mule reveals that he
suspects the second foundation is
located on the planet as in de the mule
places a hyper relay on their ship so
that he can track them through
hyperspace initially channeis and
preacher land on the planet rasam it is
a barren planet controlled by two Zinda
the pair meet the governor of Rossum but
he appears to be ordinary printer
confronts Janus and he is suspicious of
him because of the success of a search
it is then that the mule himself appears
and reveals that he is aware that Janus
is in fact a member of the second
foundation who has been aware of the
Mules plans the mill uses his mint aleck
abilities to place preacher in a deep
sleep after his conditioning is broken
by the Mules conversation with Janus the
mule then reveals to channeis that he
has already brought ships to Taz in de
and destroyed the planet both the mule
can sense that Janus is not truly
dismayed by the lost Essendon it
couldn't be the true location of the
second foundation the mule forces
channeis to reveal that the planet they
are on called Rossum is in fact the true
location of the second foundation but
even this is revealed to be false when
the first speaker of the second
foundation appears he tells the mule
that his rule is now over
neither Azam nor Taz inda wherever the
locations of the second foundation Janus
had been implanted with false knowledge
by the second foundation intended to
mislead the mule the second foundation
is already headed to the planet clag on
and all the rest of the first foundation
worlds to undo the damage that the mule
has done d converting the inhabitants of
the Empire the mule knows his fleet is
too far away to prevent this and in that
moment he is overcome with despair it is
here that the first speaker has his
chance he is able to seize control of
the Mules mind and alter it
the mule will return to clag on and live
out the rest of his life as a benevolent
despotic ruler he died prematurely from
poor health brought on by his mutations
the mule would be the biggest threat
ever to the plan of Harry Sheldon
developed by use of psychohistory the
second foundation however was able to
restore the balance and place humanity
back on the proper track
the Mules life was a tragic and short
one the character in my opinion should
be remembered as one of the most
intriguing science-fiction antagonists
of all time